Ugghhh.
Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's morning, but I still see the moon and
that star that you're probably gonna tell
me tomorrow is actually a planet.
Alright, it's a little bit later and I'm in
a better mood now.
Plus I'm vlogging from the car; that always
makes me happy.
So Hank, I really enjoyed your history of
the Pizza John design, but it made me wonder
about the history of pizza, and also the history
of Johns.
We're gonna start with the history of pizza,
but first we have to define what we mean when
we talk about pizza.
I mean, we live in an age of cheeseless pizza,
and sauceless pizza, and none pizza with left
beef.
Now some people say that pizza is just like
bread with toppings, and so they trace it
back to Ancient Egypt and India and Greece.
But Hank, I think we all know that those people
are wrong, I mean garlic naan is not pizza.
Banana bread is not pizza.
Pizza is bread and tomato sauce and cheese
and possibly other.
And by that definition, the history of pizza
becomes a lot more interesting, because for
almost all of human history, pizza was impossible.
Pizza's central ingredients lived in entirely
different worlds, Hank.
In the Americas, there were delicious tomatoes.
And in the rest of the world, there was wonderful
cows' milk and bread.
But then, Christopher Columbus.
Now, Hank, as discussed in this video - and
you will notice my excellent pointing skills.
Anyway, the exchange between the Americas
and the rest of the world that began with
Columbus, in the late fifteenth century, was
disastrous for life on Earth in many, many
ways.
But it did make pizza possible, and also like
90% of the foods that we now eat.
I mean, hamburgers and french fries?
There were no cows in the New World, no potatoes
in the Old World.
I mean, can you imagine going to a restaurant
and being like, "hey, can I have a hamburger
and French fries?", and them being like, "Well,
you can have french fries, but if you want
the hamburger ,you're gonna have to leave
the Americas".
Well, among the many New World foods that
came to the Old World was tomatoes, which
was initially believed to be poisonous, but
it turns out that they are just dangerously
delicious.
And by the middle of the sixteenth century,
in Naples, Italy, we had pizza as we know
it today, with cheese, and tomato sauce, and
bread and possibly other.
But like most things, Hank, pizza didn't actually
have an inventor, it had, like, millions of
innovators.
Like, for instance, the pizza in sixteenth
century Naples tasted very little like pizza
as we know it today.
For one thing, it was sweet, like pizza literally
means 'pie'.
So the story of pizza is really a story of,
like, humans coming together over thousands
of generations and across continents to invent
the perfect food.
And that's what history is, really, Hank,
it's not really about great individuals, it's
this ongoing collaboration among the ninety
six billion or so people who have lived here.
Alright, Johns!
John comes from the Hebrew name meaning 'God
is gracious', and for, like, a thousand years
it was the most popular name in England, until,
like, I was born and then suddenly it became
less popular.
I'm trying not to take that personally.
There's a few minor Johns in the Hebrew Bible,
but the Johns really took off in the New Testament.
I don't want to brag, Hank, but there are
no Hanks in the New Testament, and there's
some pretty vital Johns.
Like, there's the itinerant preacher John
the Baptist, Jesus' apostle John...
Historians disagree about whether there are
other Johns in the Bible, and I'm going to
steer clear of that argument because I'm no
dummy!
But anyway Hank, the most interesting thing
I learned in my research is that the name
John is not the same name as the name Jonathan.
Jonathan comes from a different Hebrew word
that means 'gift from God', and it's a longer
form not of John, but of Nathan.
So there you have it Hank, a brief history
of pizza and Johns.
It happens to be lunchtime.
You'll never guess what I'm having.
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.